we will now talk about how this issue of
zeros in randomized algorithm be
addressed and it's not a minor annoyance
it's actually a serious issue because
randomized algorithm do not work do not
like working with these zeros we will
now learn how to deal with these zeros
in the profile matrix and in real world
there is always a possibility
that we do not observe one of the
possible event in this case the assign
them empirical probability zero but in
fact they're real probability is not
zero it's simply the size of our sample
is too small and randomized algorithms
their performance in a serious way
that's why we need to learn how to get
rid of zeros fortunately Laplace helped
us to figure out how to do this Laplace
calculated the probability that the Sun
will not rise tomorrow given the fact
that it has risen in the last 5,000
years and actually this probability is
roughly one in two millionths according
to Laplace his estimate was ridiculed
because his opponent didn't realize how
important this calculation was now so if
we repeat an experiment that can result
in a success or failure n times and get
s successes then what is the probability
that the next repetition will be a
success in other word if X 1 X 2 X n
plus 1 are conditionally independent
random variables boolean random
variables of a failure correspond to 0
and success correspond to 1 that
traditional way to compute probability
of xn plus 1 is simply compute the
fraction on successes in 1 Z among all
trials so it will be s divided by
however since we have a prior knowledge
then successes and failures exist then
they actually had two more observations
implicitly even before we started our
trials so even before they started our
trials we should acknowledge that
success and failure are possible and
therefore there are two more invisible
events that was Laplace argument and
therefore he made a correction based on
the fact that when we see an event we
actually see n plus two events and when
we see s successes we actually see s
plus one successes and the formula
change to s plus 1 divided 2 n plus 2 it
may sound counterintuitive but let's see
how Laplace would get rid of zeroes in
the profile matrix so we in this case
what we need to do to update the profile
matrix to get rid of 0 according to the
Laplace rule of succession we should
assume a possibility that every event
represented in the profile matrix can OQ
and therefore visual dad wants to every
entry of profile matrix and here I show
how Laplace would update the profile the
count matrix by adding ones to all
entries as a result profile matrix also
will get updated all probabilities will
get updated and we will get rid of all
zeroes in probability
now instead of rolling one sided dice we
can actually roll seven sided dice and
based on the result of seven sided dice
we will choose a new instance of the
motive in the sequence here is
afterwards the iterate and let's see how
our motifs are changing so starting from
this we once again continue this Gibbs
sampler remove one of the sequences form
motive matrix built count matrix updated
via shoot accounts by adding ones to
every entry compute profile matrix once
again compute probability of every
Kaymer
and once again roll seven sided dice the
solenoid dice leads to changing once
again one of the choices of our motive
and we start in new iteration again we
randomly remove one of the sequences
construct count matrix apply Laplace
rule of succession create profile
calculate probability again row seven
sided dice and we arrive to the most
advanced again starting from completely
random Mattia in just three iterations
we almost captured the correct implanted
motifs which means that the bias that
implanted might've introduced was
correctly captured by Gibbs sampler and
led us to the correct method we are not
still there because in the second
sequence we have not found the correct
motive yet but surely at the next
iteration with this high probability
we'll find it so we are almost done
obvious covering randomized algorithm
but the challenge of predicting the
generative signal remains remember how
randomized motif search did not have did
not find the perfect binding site for
this motif what can we do well there is
one possibility maybe maybe they can
develop even better algorithm finding
motives but if you think about this
imagine that you insert not mighty
movies of lands for 15 of these for
mutations but motive of lands 15 movies
5 mutations finding this mighty was
almost impossible not because we don't
have efficient algorithm but because
random motives start competing with
these real motives simply statistically
it is not point it may not be possible
to find this might've in
we implant them in long DNA strengths
for example
into strength of lambs South what can be
done should we give up in this case
biologists did not give up and because
they and the way to solve this problem
today is to resort to the techniques
which is called cheap sequencing and
essentially what chip-sequencing does it
reduces the length of DNA strength to
look for regulatory materials as I
mentioned when you assert a elusive
pattern in the strengths of land
thousand it may not be possible even to
find it even with the best available
algorithm but if biologist Reed used the
area where to look for motive let's say
from thousand to one hundred then
suddenly statistics work in our favor
and we can find such motives and this is
the end of the story about randomized
out there